at moments of low self-esteem it can be
hard to avoid the fear that we may and
this might explain certain relationship
hiccups be really quite bad in bed three
anxieties tend to predominate that our
bodies are not attractive enough that we
don't practice or know about certain
positions and that we tire too easily
these fears reflect an underlying view
that sex is predominantly an athletic or
aerobic activity and that therefore good
sex must hinge on a capacity to flex our
bodies optimally but this risks
misunderstanding what lies at the core
of eroticism for those sex traditionally
makes use of our bodies sexual pleasure
may more accurately be thought of as
stemming from certain maneuvers of the
mind as new technology is showing us
it's quite possible for two people to
generate extraordinary eroticism while
their bodies are a continent or more
apart
that's because errata sysm is in truth
about something else entirely ideas
being a good lover is first and foremost
a skill of the mind sex grows
pleasurable the more it functions as a
release from a great many of the ideas
of what is normal that dominate in
non-sexual life good sex allows us to
admit to and share a maximal amount of
what we must normally keep hidden in
good sex we will for example be allowed
to show that we're more interested in
controlling and dominating someone than
we normally let on or conversely that
we're very keen to submit and be
entirely weak we might want to subvert
the hierarchies of normal life by
exploring scenarios of pilots and cabin
attendants professors and students
patients and doctors we might confess
that though monogamous by nature the
idea of other people watching us or
joining us excites us really rather a
lot or we may reveal that our erotic
interests don't actually as they're
meant to circle exclusively around
genitals that we're really pretty
interested in more incidental things
like wrists or the back of necks or
indeed shoes or tights
we might be brave enough to challenge
the normal Krahn
logical rules revealing that we'd like
to spend a hugely long time with our
clothes still on or indeed rush straight
in without decorum sexiness is the
excitement of feeling released from the
restrictive taboos of the rest of our
lives it's a safe mutually caring place
where we can take someone else into the
not entirely responsible somewhat cruel
and mad sides of us that someone gives
us permission to do this that is at the
core of what sexiness is the person who
is good in bed
therefore isn't the one who knows how to
articulate themselves rhythmically for
extended periods it's the person who
encourages endorses and legitimates our
secret lonely selves at the same time as
being very aware of and honest about
their own private wishes and enthusiasms
it's about a mutual nakedness of the
mind made possible through trust
you